salut à tous cette vidéo est sponsorisée
par norvpn imaginez vous partez en
vacances à l'aéroport votre téléphone
est piratés par des terroristes
internationaux qui ont accès total à vos
données privé ils se servent de la vidéo
trouvée sur votre portable où vous tirez
les moustaches de votre chat Hector et
la m en ligne votre réputation est
ruinée vous perdez votre emploi votre
femme et vos enfants et en plus vous
payez l'avion 13 € trop cher tout cela
ne serait jamais arrivé avec norvpn
norvpn le partenaire idéal pour vos
vacances d'été protégez votre connexion
sur les réseaux Wifi Public hôtel
restaurant aéroport et en vous
connectant à un serveur étranger faites
des économie sur vos réservations de vol
ou de location de voiture par exemple
vous bénéficiez de tarif préférentiel
pour réserver un hôtel à
lianvpulir
gilger queinop ça va non [ __ ] tu m'as
interrompu maintenant je dois te refaire
des tarifs préférentiels pour réserver
un hôtel Alen
P bref le nom complet c'est ça voilà et
les habitants du coin il l'appelle
yenfer c'est P de Gal bonjour l'étranger
c'est pas toujours qu'on a des visiteurs
à LVA P Queen k Queen vous pouvez aussi
aller dans une autre ville he ça marche
pour tous les
pays et en vous géolocalisant en France
continuez de profiter de vos contenus
favoris ou vos abonnements depuis
l'étranger obtenez n VPN au meilleur
prix en passant par le lien en
description oh oh ah oh [ __ ] c'est
vrai que ça fait 14 ans ah tu as trouvé
quelque chose ah mais j'en ai trouvé une
autre c'est un reportage sur la guerre
en Irak en
[Musique]
2003 c'est pas la guerre en irac ça
attends ça arrive je crois que nous
avons une F de pétrole je vais mettre le
feux à tout ça effectivement ouais ah
attends il y a un nouveau
personnage Onar
c'est pas mal je la garderai pour plus
tard mais c'est pas ça qu'on cherche ça
c'est trop récent on cherche un truc
plus vieux attends j'ai quelque chose
pour
[Musique]
toi Seb on n'est pas dans une SITEC il
faut que tu me dises à quoi tu penses
attends j'ai cassette
[Musique]
ok c'est vraiment une
cassette vas-y Casimir ah mais non mais
ça c'est trop vieux c'est Casimir quoi
on était même pas né c'est vrai mais en
même temps est-ce que tu t'es déjà
demandé d'où venaient les émissions
jeunesse avant le club doroté pas du
tout et bien justement laisse lae-moi te
[Musique]
répondre 1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les émissions jeunesse enfin de ma
jeunesse on en a beaucoup parlé déjà
club d' minium dek TV mais ça vient d'où
en fait on n jamais essayé de remonter
plus loin au niveau chronologique je
pense qu'on peut affirmer que les
meupettes et SESAM Street aux États-Unis
ont beaucoup influencé ce qui s'est fait
par dans le monde en France à cette
période les programmes sont tous un peu
dispersés donc il faut bien suivre le
programme télé et s'accrocher pour
savoir qu'on va trouver chapis chapeau
le manège enchanté ou bonne nuit les
petits à une certaine heure de la
journée oh mais ferm V gu ah qu'est-ce
que c'était violent à l'époque les
émissions bordel l'ORTF l'ancêtre de
toutes les chaînes publiques crée une
adaptation de SESAM Street pour la
France sous le nom de bonjour sésame
remonté avec des morceaux d'épisodes
mais problème l'émission ne dispose pas
d'assez d'images la chaîne crée donc un
programme spécialement pour remplir les
4 minutes manquantes et ce sera l'île
aux enfants que vous connaissez au moins
forcément de nom pour le fameux
personnage de Casimir et son générique
[Musique]
culte et oui Casimir à la base c'était
juste un spin-off d'une adaptation
française de SESAM Street en 75 Casimir
a tellement de succès que l'Î aux
enfants deviendra un show à partentière
qui fera plus de 1000 émissions mais je
vous connais pas vous ah vous êtes
encore jamais venu sur l'île aux enfants
c'est bien ce que je me disais bienvenue
sur l'île aux enfants waouh l'île aux
enfants est-ce que casimer est là ah non
désolé par contre on a bill Clinton Joe
Biden et jeffre Stein là-bas génial et à
ce moment-là les émissions jeunesse sont
très différentes de ce qu'on verra plus
tard hein ça dure tout juste une
vingtaine de minutes pas de dessin animé
encore hein juste quelques séquences
pour entrecouper le tout souvent à base
de marionette ou de petites animations
dont la plus connue de nos jours est
sûrement l'alinéa une production
italienne l'îlex enfants durera jusqu'en
1982 moment où Casimir en perte de
vitesse sera remplacé par le village
dans les nuages une autre émission avec
des grosses mascottes de dinosaures sur
la même formule entrecoupé exactement
pareil par des segments avec des
marionnettes et des protodessins animés
mais bah c'est pareil on n'est pas
encore dans le format d'émission
jeunesse tel qu'on le connaît et pour ça
il faudra regarder du côté de Antenne 2
avec Récréa 2 à l'époque récré 2 enfin
Récréa 2 quel plaisir réellement là
qu'on y trouve l'origine des émissions
jeunesse t qu'on les connaît et récré à
de je me rends compte qu'on en a très
peu parlé alors que finalement c'est
vraiment le proto club de roté il y a
déjà toute l'équipe au complet Jacky
Arian Corbier tout le monde est déjà là
et cette émission finalement c'est même
plus une révolution pour la télé que ne
l'a été le club doroté puisque le club
doroté se contentera juste de récupérer
la formule et de la perfectionner et
heureusement qu'ils ont récupéré le club
d'au hein parce que les émissions
jeunesse sur TF1 avant le club d'O elles
étaient bizarres le montage des
composants se fera sur la barrette de
Domino le transistor est à brancher au
bornes 2 3 et 4
attention tous les transistors possèdent
un sens de branchement et c'était tous
les jours un nouveau petit segment
éducatif nous vous proposons ici une
méthode de fabrication très simple avec
un cristal de sulfate de
cuivre il vous faut une coupelle plate
un agitateur une éprouvette graduée un
flacon d'eau disyé un bocal un récha une
casserole et voilà de la cristal m et
comme c'est mon fils qui l'a fait il est
juridiquement irresponsable allez bonne
journée tout le monde et bonne journée d
bien allez mais avec rcré 2 on est déjà
là une formule qui est bien avancée et
qui propose des vrais gros dessins
animés sérieux récré à 2 c'est Albator
c'est goldorac c'est Candy capitaine
flamme c'est Paul position qui était
déjà là incroyable l'émission lutté à
l'époque contre entre son principal
concurrent qui au début des années 80
était FR3 jeunesse qui eux avaient tous
les trucs français les entrechats toute
la série des il était une fois et toutes
les productions de chez Dick avec Ulis
31 Inspecteur Gadget et cetera et après
bon la fin de l'histoire vous la
connaissez TF1 se fait privatiser en
1987 confie la case jeunesse à
jean-lucazoulet qui déboche toute
l'équipe à doroté de récré à 2 et
rachète des animés japonais au
kilomètres à la to dans la foulée Récréa
2 se casse la gueule et TF1 créera le
club doroté club doroté
qui nous amènera donc la fameuse seconde
vague des animés japonais à partir de
1987 la plus connue très certainement
puisque c'est la vague de Dragon Ball de
Nicky Larson ou des chevaliers du
zodiaque et je sais que je l'ai déjà dit
auparavant mais cette seconde vague sera
un événement générationnel majeur
puisque c'est elle qui transformera la
France en le deuxième plus gros
consommateur de manga juste derrière le
Japon et c'est important pour une autre
raison c'est que cette arrivée massive
d'animé japonais sur les chaînes
françaises va également même changer le
public cible de ces en jeunesse ce qui
était quelques années avant destiné
vraiment aux enfants va de plus en plus
s'adresser aux jeunes adolescents et
forcément qu'elle le survivant même avec
les doublages marrants c'est pas trop
fait pour des enfants de 6 ans mais
qu'est-ce qui se serait passé si on
avait jamais eu le club d'au en France
ou du moins qu'est-ce qui serait passé
si on avait jamais eu cette arrivée
massive de manga à la fin des années 80
peut-être que DBZ seraiit arrivé bien
plus tard sur nos écrans peut-être que
le club doroté n'aurait pas fait
exploser TF1 qui serait resté une chaîne
un petit peu en retrait comme M6
peut-être qu'on aurait pas pu payer 40 €
nos billet pour aller le samedi à la
Japan Expo moi je
sais qui êtes-vous moi je suis guilire
je suis le cousin de Jean-Louis la
chaussette attendez une minute ses yeux
globuleux ses antennes poilues et ce
maillage en coton si particulier qui
permettrait de tenir mon pied bien au
chaud vous êtes québécois exact mon chum
puis aujourd'hui je viens t'aider pour
parler des émissions étrangères attache
ta tuuc avec de la broche on y va je
suis désolé je comprends pas un de ce
que vous dites vous pouvez parler
français voyons donc Alice je parle déjà
français tu es pas en train de me souer
là non si tu veux savoir à quoi
ressemblaient les émissions sans club de
roté il suffit d'aller voir ce qui se
faisilleur qu'en France effectivement
pour imaginer un monde sans le club
d'eau le meilleur moyen c'est peut-être
tout simplement d'aller voir à
l'étrangerci BL par exemple en Belgique
ici blabla une émission jeunesse qui
durera de 94 à juin 2010 émission
jeunesse visiblement présentée par une
marionnette de Alain Jupé bercé trop
près d'un mur un choix bizarre mais bon
après tout c'est la Belgique et tout de
suite un extrait hors contexte une maman
une vraie
MAM
consolement cette émission va être
longue mais cette émission est assez
représentative c'était une émission très
importante en Belgique mais surtout
c'était une émission jeunesse encore
faite pour les jeunes elle est donc
présentée par blabla c'est cette petite
créature là dont on ne saurait dire si
c'est un enfant ou un adulte il est
l'enfant de carte mère c'est
l'ordinateur et accompagné par ces deux
amis une souris femelle qui aime bien
les ordinateurs du nom de clic ouais
grosse imagination décidément sur les
noms et son fiancé [ __ ] qui a l'air
d'être une personne charmante notamment
dans cet épisode où [ __ ] amène sa
fiancée dans les égouts et essaie de
mettre du GHB dans sa pardon un filtre
d'amour dans sa boisson mais que ça ne
marche pas et du coup dans un élan
interraciale elle saute sur blabla pour
qu'est-ce que tu fais là toi oh mais non
c'est
pas je t'aime je
t'aim bref je vous fais pas un D ça
l'émission avait même quelques guimiic
les spectateurs étaient appelés des
lardons leurs parents étaient appelés
des croûtons et ell se finissaient
toujours par un truc qui s'appelle le
cache-cache pub petite chanson où en
gros blabla chante sur le fait qu'il ne
faut pas regarder la
publicité je bouge mes yeux
je cache mes
oreilles et je regarde
pas la
[Musique]
PUB la pub moi je suis comme les copains
j'adore l'émission était bien sûr
entrecoupée de blablatoscope
c'est-à-dire des dessins animés avec
comme particularité quand même qu'il ne
s'agissait que de dessins animés
européen mais si les Belges se
souviennent de ici blabla c'était bien
sûr davantage pour les personnages pour
le visage de l' mission pour blabla
parce que chaque petite séquence avec
les marionnettes était l'occasion de
donner de la profondeur au personnag
comme cette émission par exemple où
blabla et clic visite des sites internet
et que clic commence à surfer sur le
Dark web bienvenue sur
ultrasevvère.com tu aimes les maîtresses
sévère oui madame
sal ouais alors les auteurs ont dû
s'amuser sur les double sens alors j'ai
envie d'une bonne engueelade j'appuie
sur de voilà petite idiote c'est toi qui
a écrit ce torchon c'est ridicule tu
confonds encore les P et les B tu n'as
pas honte tu es la honte de ta famille
la honte de la classe la honte de
l'école la honte de moi-même de tes
camarades dieu merci le ciel me préserve
d'être ta mère et maintenant tu vas
prendre tes cliqus et tes claques et
aller tout droit chez le
directeur waouh bravo c'était génial oh
elle est vraiment infect c'est tout à
fait l'ambiance de la classe wouh euh on
peut envoyer la police chez elle pour
être sûr que tout se passe bien dans sa
famille bon après pas d'inquiétude ça
resté une émission jeunesse bon enfant
on s'embrasse avec la avec
la la plupart du temps chaque émission
était donc une aventure pour blabla et
ses amis et en l'occurrence dans
celle-ci ils commencent à créer leur
propre site Internet pour les profs qui
ont envie d'avoir des élèves un petit
peu difficiles alors voyons voir
ultrachauu.com merveilleux enfin des
élèves
teigneux tout ça alors qu'elle aurait pu
attendez une seconde j'avais un
commentaire politique pertinent à faire
sur les jeunes et sur l'éducation mais
ça a été effacé du script bienvenue sur
ultrachu.com un site destiné aux
instituteurs et aux institutrices
amateur d'élèves insupportable
impertinent et imp si vous voulez un ch
tapz un si vous voulez entendre des gros
mots tapez sur deux si vous voulez voir
voler des cocottes en papier des avions
fusés tapz sur 3 si vous voulez la
totale appuyez sur 4 oh oui 4 4 4 je m
pas lesou
bâtard va te faire [ __ ] arrête de
m'agresser j'ai rien dit du tout ah
c'était une autre époque
limage cacou CAC oh ils sont merveilleux
ils sont merveilleux bah bon si ça en
reste là ça peut aller
merveilleux oh quelle vie quelle
vitalité quelle énergie c'est
merveilleux j'adore ça j'espère qu'ils
vont venir brûler ma voiture et me suive
jusqu'à chez moi avec T coues
sachez aussi d'ailleurs que comme
dorotthé chez nous ici blabla c'était
aussi des chansons qui ont marqué la
Belgique comme
couscous les crottes de chiens
[Musique]
des et bien
d'autres
virus évidemment al c'était pas la seule
émission jeunesse il y avait d'autres
émissions pirate nubba megga mind une
sorte de fantô belge app mais c'est très
dur de trouver des sources sur ces
émissions et ici blabla c'était
finalement quand même la plus connue
petit aparté sur les voisins en Suisse
on trouvera verpom une vieille émission
des années 70 qui faisait des petites
parodies Basile Pora dans la même époque
et dans les années 90 les Bab bouchett
une émission avec des
[Musique]
chaussettes j'avou que les suissesz qu
Mme faire comment ça au Maghreb pas
d'émission en français dans les années
90 tout était déjà en arabe grand diiser
captaine Majid pour Olivier Tom leur
émission jeunesse viendra finalement
surtout après les années 2000 depuis des
chaînes du Moyen-Orient comme spaceeton
et mbc3 et en vrai de toute façon les
Algériens et les Marocains avaient dans
leur grande majorité des paraboles ce
qu'il fait qu'ils regardaient le club de
roté tout comme nous ils sontir vos pays
en Europe là et où la valeur éducative
dans tout ça attends on avait aussi une
valeur éducative nous hein regarde ça on
avait ja dans des costumes d'époque on
apprenait
l'histoire
[Musique]
sold que
voulezvous vous ne voyez pas que je suis
en réunion extraordinaire avec les petit
mademois français je crois que c'est la
France pendant la guerre la leçon du
jour ah regardez ça c'est pas beau de
voir tous ces enfants hurler de joie
devant un mec déguisé un a qui hurle
pour faire venir une chanteuse étrangère
voil jeis que cette image vous savez ça
reste un beau souvenir pour
elle et puis on avait aussi des
personnages qui rendaient hommage aux
autres culture ça va je crois que j'ai
compris effectivement vous arrive pas
à est-ce que tu en es sûr et oui bien
sûr c'est évidemment au Québec qu'on va
trouver le plus de trucs bizarres et on
va remonter loin dans qu' faire en
commençant par you en
Marc Bruno
[Musique]
blaisep Claudette Simon you on n pas
menti sur la marchandise ça s'appelle
you je saurais pas trop comment décrire
ça les mecs essaient de toucher leur nez
avec la langue la femme se touche le
visage comme si elle venait de découvrir
qu'elle avait des mains il y a des
extraits vraiment bizarres en
calédoscope des moments où tout le monde
se tient la main et fait la farandol oui
ben je je demanderais bien de voir leur
analyse d'urine quand même juste pour
être sûr ben écoutez justement je viens
de terminer ces alise ah non c'est pas
la bonne c'est
celle-là bizarrement tout est normal
c'était pas la seule émission du genre
tenz une petite question pour vous
est-ce que vous pensez que Jésus est
flexible je me courbe je me déplie je me
replie je suis flexible la réponse est
oui mais allez tout ça remonte un petit
peu trop loin et s'il y a bien un point
commun entre toutes les émissions
québécoises c'est qu'elles doivent être
éducative et déjà éducative ne serait-ce
que par rapport au fait que le pays est
bilingue et qu'il faut donc apprendre
autant le français que l'anglais et ça
dès le plus jeune âge et c'est pour
cette raison qu'on trouvait là-bas des
émissions comme téléfrançais diffusé à
partir de 85 non pas au Québec pour le
coup mais sur la chaîne téléontario
émission destinée aux anglophones pour
leur apprendre le français
bonjour tu parles mais tu es un ananas
tu es un ananas
oui c'est vrai je suis un ananas je je
suis un ananas et tu parles ce n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas possible ça veut
rien dire les ananas ça peut parler
[Musique]
regardez-moi alors oui un ananas parlant
qui vit dans une décharge c'est étrange
mais dites-vous qu'ils vont quand même
tenir 30 épisodes avec ce concept après
le générique Jacques le garçon qui joue
comme un texte to speech et rejoint SOP
sa copine le synthétiseur vocal et
qu'est-ce que c'est ça vient de là-bas
non ça vient de là-bas ça vient de là
haut tout bien
sûr c'est un avion
oui oui bon on va pas tous retaper hein
bon bref il y a un avion qui arrive et
avec lui un nouveau personnage qui pour
aucune raison particulière est joué par
une marionnette bonjour je suis
pilote pardon
je suis pilote
ouais moi ça me rassurerait pas de
monter avec une meuf comme ça bonjour je
suis pilote
ok on va prendre le train je suis
fasciné par la capacité de cette
émission à toujours prendre une
direction inattendue tu veux un verre
d'eau et voici un verre
d'eau verre
d'eau non merci je veux de la musique
et voici les
squelettes nous nous appelons les
squelettes nous nous appelons
lesquelettes
nous on dirait les rêves que tu fais
quand tu as de la fièvre bon alors après
ça continue je vais passer les détails
la pilote demande aux enfants s'ils sont
prêts bon vous êtes prêts pourquoi pour
le saut en
parachute il y a aussi des fois des
petits sondages pour inclure le public
par exemple est-ce que nanana peut
sauter en parachute les résultats sont
oui 2 milli
864327 bah c'est pas malin ça apprend à
la fois aux enfants le principe du vote
et le fait qu'on puisse dire n'importe
quoi et inventer les résultats ou alors
est-ce que Sophie est réponse a un
squelette réponse B une criminelle
réponse C une fille ou réponse d un
corbeau ou c'est à peu près les mêm chos
qu'on a eu aux dernières élections
présidentielles avec des mélanges donc
la pilote enlève les enfants pour les
amener dans son avion et pour les faire
sauter en parachute enfant qui je
précise don à aucun moment dit oui c'est
100 % un enlèvement je ne veux pas
sauter en parachute moi non plus
attention c'est bientôt le moment tu
veux le verre d'eau non je voudrais
revoir mes parents madame mais non comme
pour le premier épisode on va avoir un
passage de musique j'aime jouer au B
j'aime jouer au
hcky j'aime beaucoup les
sport que
j'adore excusez-moi dans combien de
temps on arrive allô
allô pilote pilote ici c'est l'heure ah
bon c'est le moment ok c'est flippant le
moment de
quoi voilà ah
quoi bye bye et maintenant
continuons c'est bon il son oui je suis
pilotes bien je vous les coordonné pour
écraser votre avion oui les ananas
peuvent sauter en parachute al vraiment
sincèrement cette émission est
surréaliste pas d'autres mots on
halluciné sur chaque passage et c'est un
truc de fou parce que tous les épisodes
se suivent il y a vraiment un fil rouge
sur les 30 épisodes et je vois même pas
à quoi ça peut servir de manière
pratique en je veux dire quand tu
apprends une langue étrangère on
t'apprend d'abord à dire bonjour merci
au revoir j'ai soif j'ai faim enfin j'en
sais rien c'est quoi l'usage pratique de
cette émission pour les enfants là
bonjour est-ce que votre ananas saute en
parachute je suis un
corbeau [ __ ] non mais les gens se
foutent de notre gueule en plus mais
c'est bon je retourne en France en
restant la série des émissions jeunesse
éducative on va avoir à partir de 88
Bibi et jeune viève alors ça sonne comme
une blague mais c'est vraiment le nom
une émission donc présenté par jeune
viève jeune dessinatrice et un
extraterrestre du nom de Bibi
z9944x qui nous font suivre leurs
aventures son design est vraiment un
cave avec parfois des épisodes engagés
hein ça parle régulièrement de la misère
dans le monde de la sécheresse en
Afrique de la pauvreté je te dis qu'il y
a eu tout un choc en apprenant que il y
avait des enfants qui souffraient à
cause de la sécheresse dans monde ou
même de jeune vièv qui fait des
pancartes pour aller manifester et puis
en plein milieu là je mets mon slogan
VIè c'est quoi ça une manifestation une
manifestation ben c'est un regroupement
de plusieurs personnes qui marchent
ensemble dans les rues pour que tout le
monde les voit bien et puis comprennent
ce qu'ils veulent mais toujours avec ce
petit ton pour enfant calme et reposant
et là tu vois bibi je tremple le tissu
dans la bouteille mais surtout faut bien
clean la bouteille pour pas que la fl l'
ne rentre dedans pu ça veut dire quoi
jeune viève bon alors dans cet épisode à
la fin bibi veut lui aussi aller
manifester mais malheureusement on nous
le montre pas c'est dommage j'aurais
bien aimé voir la fin et là tu vois bibi
ça s'appelle une bour et là je vais
prendre des poivre dans les yeux on
avait aussi des moments touchants dans
cette émission comme quand jeune viève
parle la bibi de l'Afrique mais oui mais
leur maison est pas seulement construite
en paille mais non ils font sécher de la
boue aussi qui mélange avec avec la
paille puis c'est avec ça qu'il
construisent le toit de leur maison
attends je viève tu sais qu'ils ont de
l'électricité en Afrique à C heure des
fois ils chante puis danse autour du feu
même parce que tu sais eux il faut
qu'ils chasse les animaux pour manger
puis qu'il pêche des poissons alors ils
ont besoin du feu pour les faire cuire
voyons s boire jeunevève dansé au Congo
ou quoi dans quel siècle tu vis tabarnac
c'était tellement mignon et éducatif ces
émissions et puis tu vois bibi parfois
quand ils ont faim il se mange entre eux
coupé oh là là je viève contente-toi de
lire le texte et contrairement à ici
blabla ici pas de sous-entendu malsin et
oui mais bibi quand même tu peux pas me
demander n'importe quoi une pipe
franchement que du bonheur et un peu de
[ __ ] dans cette même période du début
des années 90 toujours au Québec on
avait aussi Lilo de Lili une émission
avec des chansons des petites animation
en dessin et un monsieur qui te lit des
petites histoires pour enfants bon après
on va pas trop en parler parce que c'est
clairement une émission pour les est
tout petit hein d'ailleurs on parle
d'émissions éducativ mais il y avait
aussi des émissions d'éducation au sport
au Québec chose que je n'ai jamais vu en
France avec enfant forme une émission au
concept étrange puisqu'elle consiste à
faire faire de l'aérobique aux jeunes
enfants plus haut on
arrive oh c'est haut oui Non Non mais
mettez les images là parce que sinon
c'est
bizarre enc
ouais en fait c'est aussi bizarre même
avec et évidemment bon même si j'admire
l'effort de vouloir faire faire du sport
à des gosses les enfants ça veut pas
faire de l'aérobique c'est quoi ces
conneries c'est un truc d'adulte ça non
mais un enfant ça veut sortir pour jouer
au foot avec ses copains ou ça veut
aller courir dans un parc et manger du
sable à côté du toboggan quoi c'est à
côté du toboggan qu'on trouve le
meilleur sable sachez-le je veux dire
prenez cet extrait oh j'aime ça faire de
l'exercice oh moi aussi si tu venais
faire d'exercice avec nous tu pourrais
voir si tu es vraiment en forme et vous
croyez vraiment qu'il y a des gosses qui
se posent cette question tu pourrais
voir si tu es vraiment en forme [ __ ]
je suis vraiment pas en forme faut
vraiment que je bouge mon gros cul
l'émission sera régulièrement agrémentée
de petites chansons pour faire du sport
alors tantôt dynamique ce qui est normal
pour du sport malgré quelques
sous-entendus bizarre je suis un gros
chien tu es un gros chameau et
tantôt juste
[Musique]
bizarre on étend une jambe on étend une
jambe on l'étend sur le côté
[Musique]
on étend l'eau de jambe on étend l'eau
de jambe on l'étend sur le
côté c'est là où on voit bien la
différence entre les opening et les
ending dans les animés on va sauter
quelques années et arriver à la fin des
années 90 où on retrouve une émission
qui s'appelle la boîte à lunch une
émission présentée par une jeune fille
de 5 ans nommée Julie pierre ce que j'ai
trouvé c'est ça quand j'étais petite
j'étais petite quoi bon alors c'est
c'est clairement horrible à écouter
quand tu es un adulte un enfant de cette
âge là qui te parle tu as l'impression
d'écouter un mec bouré le principe de
l'émission c'est que la jeune fille a
une boîte à lunch magique je vais à
l'école avec elle qu' voit régulièrement
en arrière-plan bon appétit madame bon
appétit à toi n parle pas c'est un
secret entre toi et moi et on la suit
donc dans sa routine avant d'aller à
l'école une sacrée routine on va pas se
mentir elle se prépare elle prend son
petit déj elle va aux toilettes elle
reçoit ses amis elle sort avec son
grand-père elle va danser dans la forêt
elle joue elle chante et ah oui et quand
même à la fin elle prend le bus pour
aller à
l'école et voilà les amis à demain pour
un autre épisode de la boîte à
lunch mais allez stope assez d'êtres
humains parce que les émissions jeunesse
au Québec c'est aussi une longue
tradition d'adules déguisé en
animaux avec des voix d'enfants et à
l'inverse de les Français qui essayit
d'apprendre aux jeunes anglophones à
parler français on a ici dans la rue
tabaga avec flip et flappp c'est ce que
je deux gros trucs dégueulasse là est-ce
qu'il est gros big mais la plus connue
des émissions québécoises avec
des furies appelons un chat un chat
c'était bien sûr cornemuse une série qui
raconte la vie d'un centre vétérinaire
dirigé par Cornemuse c'est elle qui vit
avec des enfants animaux et qui soignent
des animaux mais qui ne sont pas comme
eux parce que ça c'est des vrais animaux
et eux c'est des enfants animaux mais du
coup ça en fait quoi alors si c'est pas
des animaux c'est quoi c'est des
expériences je veux dire comment c'estjà
là tu commences à poser trop de question
là du coup pour comprendre alors je suis
allé sur leur site internet cordemus.com
bon alors j'ai rien trouvé mais juste
pour dire que ce site est incroyable
c'est un vrai petit retour dans
l'Internet des années 2000 ah non je
n'ai pas le plugin Flash ça n'existe
plus depuis 2017 en fait bref revenons à
la série je vais pas mentir en tant
qu'adulte à regarder il y a un côté très
dérangeant dans le fait de voir ces
femmes adultes qui ont clairement des
corps de femmes adultes mais qui
prennent des voix et des comportements
d'enfant le tout déguisé en animaux tu
as un peu l'impression d'avoir mis les
pieds dans une communauté de déviantard
de Sonic non mais d'autant plus que
attendez ils sont habillé ou pas du coup
je veux dire cornemuse elle porte une
blouse n'est-ce pas donc il porte des
vêtements je suis pas fou d'accord donc
ça veut dire que sur cette image là oui
c'est important après excusez-moi c'est
sûrement moi qui vois des sous-entendus
là où il y en a pas et mon petit minou à
moi il va être tout blanc vous me
facilitez pas la tâche l'émission
destinée aux trèsjeunes enfants a duré 4
saison de 99 à 2003 sur TéléQuébec et
c'est une des émissions les plus
marquantes du pays avec un fil rouge et
des personnages qui vivent des petites
aventures des chansons et des reportages
filmés avec des vrais gosses des enfants
pour les Québécois mais si c'est une des
émissions les plus connues ça n'est pas
l'émission la plus connue parce que ce
grand titre revient à passe partartout
une émission qui pour les Québécois est
à peu près l'équivalent pour nous du
club d'oroté en France enfin ou plutôt
de récré à de vu l'époque en terme
d'importance 289 émissions de 30 minutes
diffusé entre 77 et 92 avec une nouvelle
version depuis 2019 sur TéléQuébec
l'émission était divisée en plusieurs
segments on avait le cœur de l'émission
avec des personnages qui vivent des
aventures des reportages éducatifs avec
des enfants et enfin des passag avec des
marionnettes oh oui pense partout
c'était vraiment cool il y avait plein
de marionnettes comme moi comment ça
comme toi et puis attendez pourquoi des
marionnettes et bien d'après Wikipédia
l'objectif premier de pass partout est
d'éculquer aux enfants la confiance en
soi et pour y parvenir on recrée un
milieu de vie qui est leur est familier
or les marionnettes permettent de
réaliser des mises en situation avec les
parents les amis les voisins ouais
effectivement dit comme ça a l'air
logique on peut regarder un extrait h
que tu sens bon
tu sens B partout partout
oh j'aimerais te prendre te faire une
grosse caresse te serrer fort
fort comme
[Musique]
ça d'accord c'est ce genre de voisin
donc oh oui je les connais ceuxlà j'ai
fait la prison avec bon alors les Mario
h d' passe partout c'est des beau yeux
c'est non sans ma barbe de Père Noël
elle est douce ma barbe de Père Noël
alors question pour les Québécois dans
les commentair est-ce que c'était
vraiment obligé de leur donner des voix
d'agresseur sexuel ouais que j'ai
retrouvé une vieille loi québécoise puis
ça oui après Dieu merci il y avait
d'autres passages avec des marionnettes
qui eux étaient beaucoup plus normau en
part les enfsfut généti au niau des bras
après évidemment comme j'ai dit les
marionnettes n'étaient pas le seul
segment de l'émission on avait surtout
les présentateurs appelés les
fantaisistes qui étaient les visages de
l'émission des personnages attachants
avec qui le public québécois a pu
grandir comme nous avec Jacky Arian ou
Corbier équipe composé donc de passe
partout passe carreau passe monagne
passe leouinge fardoch j'ai dit fardoch
et qui vivaent tous des petites
histoires où faisaient diverses petites
animations pour les enfants qui
regardaient
l'émission alors je sais pas si ça peut
vous intéresser mais j'ai mis une
version 10h de ça dans la description de
la vidéo avec le temps l'émission a bien
sûr évoluer la qualité des marionnettes
également pour devenir moins flippante
enfin je crois et c'est assez amusant de
se dire que même en 2023 alors que
l'émission a repris depuis quelques
années à peine ils ont quand même gardé
exactement le même format depuis les
marionnettes jusqu'au style de vêtements
alors finalement que dire ben c'est un
peu ce que j'ai dit en début de cette
vidéo en France le club de roté en
diffusant massivement des dessins animés
qui étaient parfois un petit peu
violents a fait l'entement dérivé les
émissions jeunesse en émission pour
jeunes ados là où dans d'autres pays on
le voit bien au Québec les émissions
jeunesses sont resté des émissions pour
les jeunes enfants quasi toutes les
émissions qu'on a vu au Québec étaient
financé par le ministère de l'Éducation
d'où la présence d'important volet
éducatifs et les relations entre
politique et télé étaiit plutôt bonne
alors qu'en France les relations étaient
plus tendues TF1 c'était engagé à faire
des programmes jeunesse éducatifs en
échange de sa concession c'est-à-dire le
droit de diffuser mais n'avait pas
respecté sa promesse et avait à la place
diffusé des kilotonnes de mangas
japonais pour faire de l'audience ce qui
peut aussi expliquer pourquoi les
politiques français dans les années 90
chient publiquement sur le club doroté P
tu en penses quoi sont pas si pire nos
émissions hein oui oui bahf ça dépend
quoi c'est pas mal drôle mais je dois
retourner sur ma planète mais attendez
une seconde comment ça quelle planète je
croyais que tu venais du Québec oui oui
c'est c'est c'est ça que j'ai dit
ouais juste pour être sûr vous pourriez
sortir de derrière ce fauteuil je veux
juste m'assurer que c'est pas un membre
de mon équipe technique qui a mis sa
main dans une chaussette et qui parle
avec une voix débile je me suis beaucoup
trop fait avoir comme ça
ok admettons que je vous crois vous
allez repartir
comment bonjour je suis pilote
il est
l'heure c'est
l'heure l'heure de
[Musique]
quoi et voilà je t'avais bien dit que
j'avais été parachuti pendant la guerre
en irac avec une chaussette
québécoise attends on est dans une s on
l' toujours été
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on étend une jambe on étend une jambe on
l'étend sur le côté
[Musique]